82 and no challenge we need to start in
five and three bench players so start me
off nice the spurs
oh man all right give me
give me calvin johnson
kellen johnson not bad but not for my
starting five though so we gotta get
some a little better than that the kings
oh my goodness what are they trying to
do here darren fox oh yeah this filter
not trying to let me go 82-0 but that's
right though we're going we're going to
bounce back the suns
devin booker now that's what i'm talking
about we got d book in the building
first player the starting five who's
next the pelicans give me brandon ingram
at the three i need a point guard power
forward center and one more bench player
come on now let's go the hornets give me
the mellow ball at the one lamellar ball
booker and ingram that's not looking too
bad here we got the timberwolves
you gotta get the cat mike in this start
in five we just need a pile forward and
one more bench player come on don't do
what's wrong the clippers give me kawhi
leonard we started off bad but y'all see
that starting five we going 82 and now
it's one more bench player the mavs give
me luca on the bench come on